Helping me out today, obviously,
is Zanna, who's been here all week, Zanna!
(audience applauds)
Best week ever.
Lovely you feel that.
I love being here.
All right, first up, to follow, Pearl.
This ultra-talented gentlemen from "RuPaul's Drag Race"
has so many amazing and transformative looks,
including one of yours truly.
Wait, you've got to see this.
I freaked out when I saw this.
Wait, wait, what, what, what.
It's just so good.
He's so me.
(Zanna laughs)
He's such a chameleon, but boy does he nail me.
Oh my goodness, girl, I love you.
Okay, Zanna.
It's your stunt double when needed.
Okay, so, to listen to, this weekend,
we're all gonna be listening to "Fat Mascara".
It's a podcast by two beauty editors, Jen and Jess.
I am obsessed, they're funny, they're frank,
they talk about beauty trends, freaky facials,
and all the products you've gotta try.
And they're just funny and really honest.
Yeah, and very smart,
extremely informed.
Very smart.
All right, to watch, "A Black Lady Sketch Show", on HBO,
created by one of my favorites,
the multitalented Robin Thede.
it's earned three Emmy nominations this year,
and it is just, I can't love it more.
I think the world of her.
All right, Zanna, your turn.
Okay, so, this weekend, I am gonna be cooking,
and I'm gonna be cooking from the book "Cook Beautiful"
by Athena Calderon.
She's a visual culinary Wiz.
She makes the most beautiful recipes,
and she teaches you how to serve them
in the chicest, most elegant way.
Yeah, well put, by the way.
I swoon, I swoon.
That's exactly it.
And finally, an entry from my little yellow book.
Yes, it's a list of my personal picks,
updated on our site every single week.
I really work hard on these, I love them,
and I absolutely have one that I'm dying to share with you.
This week, I just added Love Tatum's Gemstone Rollers.
First of all, I recommend also putting them in the fridge.
(Zanna gasps)
For massive de-puffing, and these are all the rage.
I mean, let's face it.
You know what?
It's like, they work, and they are lymphatic drainage,
and you do an upright motion,
and you can go with the small side around the eyes.
I mean, let's face it.
Sometimes, I just wanna do this, you know what I mean?
(general laughter)
There's also another beauty trend
I'm hoping is gonna come alive.
Roll the footage.
Yeah.
(general laughter)
That's so amazing.
I'm hoping that someone could put one of those
in the fridges, and just get on my face,
if you know what I mean, all right?
But, also, everyone in the VFFs is getting one of these.
(audience applauds)
Wait!
So, stick it in that fridge, and roll it on that face.
Love.
Okay, so, everyone also, all VFFs,
are also getting a little something from Milk Makeup
after our lovely week together.
We're gonna give everyone our "Here for the Party" sets.
So, it's basically a selection of our seven hero minis.
You got our number one best-selling Hydro Primer there,
our little KUSH eyebrow gel, our KUSH mascara, our eyeliner,
our solid Watermelon Serum, which is perfect
for rehydrating tired holiday faces,
and also, a little Vegan Milk Moisturizer.
(audience applauds)
That is so awesome, Zanna.
Thank you so much for doing that.
I mean, Milk works with the best labs.
You are going to freak out for these multitasking formulas.
Thank you, Zanna, and you know what?
Inspired by that, everybody in the wall
is also getting a $50 gift card for flowerbeauty.com,
so you can treat yourself to anything that speaks to you.
So, lots of good stuff for everybody today.
So well deserved.
Play, express, enjoy, take care of oneself,
here, here, and here.
And I just have to say, Zanna, let's stand up,
because I need everyone to see that outfit of yours,
by the way.
My Victoria Beckham outfit.
Not bad, hey?
Oh my God.
It is everything.
Your looks on this show, by the way, are stellar,
like, goals.
Oh, thank you, Zanna.
Absolute goals, beautiful.
You are one of my fashion icons,
and everybody turns to you.
I mean, Editor at Large, Marie Claire,
E! News correspondent.
Fashion is such a big part of your life.
So, if you're liking
what Lee Harris is doing, then...
Go, Lee.
Lee Harris!
All right, everybody, what a week it's been.
We're gonna do this again, Zanna, I love you.
Everybody, have a safe and happy and healthy weekend.
(upbeat music)